[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
mit niedrigen jury freut mich sehr dass
sie wieder dabei sind in allen ein ganz
herzliches willkommen zu allem was
wichtig ist und wird und das sportliche
update über den heute wieder katja
stresow das mache ich gerne schöne guten
abend dann schauen wir jetzt auf einige
unserer themen
dramatische appelle gesundheitsminister
sparen befürchtet wegen krone einen
bitteren dezember für ärger vieler ist
es bereits fünf nach zwölf
mächtig wie mao in china lässt sich
parteichef skijumping eine anhaltende
führungsrolle verleihen vielleicht sogar
auf lebenszeit
und neun tore für jogi mit einem
schützenfest gegen liechtenstein
bereitet die deutsche elf ihrem
ex-trainer einen großen abschied
die ganze woche schon seit montag
beginnen wir unsere 19 uhr ausgaben
jeweils mit corona und auch heute ist
das der fall die allermeisten
gesundheitsexperten und wissenschaftler
halten die aktuelle phase für ernst bis
dramatisch das hat auch die
pressekonferenz mit dem
gesundheitsminister und dem lka chef
verdeutlicht und die fakten sprechen für
sich die zahlen schnell nämlich weiter
ungebremst in die höhe
48.600 40 neue fälle meldet das robert
koch institut heute das sind 11 1520
mehr als vor einer woche außerdem wurden
191 weitere todesfälle registriert
die sieben tage inzidenz erreicht schon
wieder einen neuen höchstwert den
fünften tag in folge
263,7 der aktuelle bundesweite wert vor
einem monat lag er noch bei
65,8 andrea maurer über die warnungen
und politischen reaktionen des tages es
gehe jetzt auch um öffentliches
bewusstsein für die dramatik der lage
sagen lothar wieler und jens spahn heute
im elli wieler hat eine karte
mitgebracht tiefrot dort wo die inzidenz
über 500 liegt die dynamik erklärt er
anhand der infektions lage von gestern
50.000 neue infektionen an einem tag so
viele wie noch nie von diesen 50.000
fällen müssen schätzungsweise
mindestens
350 auf die intensivstation und nach
einiger zeit werden von diesen fünf 1000
menschen mindestens 200 verstärken jens
spahn warnt vor einem bitteren dezember
und geht als geschäftsführender
ministerpräsident
morgan wird es wieder kostenlose bürger
tests geben die vergütung für mediziner
wird erhöht von 20 auf 28 euro pro
corona impfung sparen spricht sich auch
dafür aus den zugang zu öffentlichen
veranstaltungen weiter zu beschränken 3g
reiche nicht mehr deshalb wäre es aus
meiner sicht aus unserer sicht
konsequent wenn wir öffentliche
veranstaltungen erstens nur für geimpfte
und genesene ermöglichen und zweitens
nur dann wenn diese zusätzlich einen
aktuellen test verweisen zweig plus auch
die ampel parteien haben heute über die
lage beraten uneinigkeit deutet sich bei
einer berufsbezogenen impfpflicht an
insofern gehe ich davon aus dass wir
eine einrichtung bezogene impfpflicht
brauchen werden um die situation im
griff zu bekommen selbstverständlich
werden wir uns der diskussion stellen
das ist ganz klar aber für uns ist auch
wichtig ob wir das mit milderen mitteln
auch erreichen können einig dass lassen
die möglichen koalitionäre wissen sind
sie sich in einem punkt einen lock down
soll es nicht mehr geben
ja mehr corona fälle das heißt auch
wieder mehr
krankenhauseinweisungen dabei gibt es
aber deutlich weniger intensivbetten
mehr als 5000 sind innerhalb eines
jahres verloren gegangen vor allem weil
durch kündigungen personal fehlt die
intensivstationen füllen sich aktuell
sind dort bundesweit
19.500 52 betten belegt und in rund
jedem siebten liegt ein komapatient
freie betten gibt es zwar noch insgesamt
gut zweieinhalb tausend aber das limit
ist vielerorts längst erreicht mediziner
schlagen alarm mehr dazu von florian
coaching
genau ein platz ist noch frei auf der
intensivstation des wald klinikums gera
jetzt rechnen sie tagtäglich damit dass
hier die kapazitätsgrenze erreicht wird
und sie aufstocken müssten zu lasten
anderer bereiche
das heißt das krankenhaus selber kann
sich ja helfen indem die nicht gewohnt
patienten versucht werden zu reduzieren
was sich auch fragwürdig ist nur wieder
op s verschieben wir ihn in den ersten
drei wellen in einigen anderen
krankenhäusern ist es schon soweit und
zwar in fast allen bundesländern
das sind patienten mit tumorerkrankungen
patienten mit gefäßerkrankungen patient
die am herzen an der lunge operiert
werden müssen und das ist natürlich
nachteilig wir sprechen ja nicht von
operationen wo man ein jahr warten kann
sondern wir reden wirklich über
dringende operation und das ist
natürlich ein riesen problem vor allem
in regionen mit hohen infektionszahlen
sei die grund- und notfallversorgung
teilweise schon stark eingeschränkt das
stellt viele ärzte auch ethisch vor
schwierige entscheidungen man kann die
zurückstellung von bestimmten
operationen bei tumor erkrankten nur
dann vornehmen wenn sie nicht absolut
dringlich sind sondern wenn sie
tatsächlich noch aufschub dulden
allerdings bedeutet ein aufschub auch
eine mögliche verschlechterung ihrer
krankheitssituation von daher ist das
auch schon gefährlich im wald klinikum
gera rechnen sie mit einer sich weiter
verschärfenden situation und das sie
bereits ende kommender woche doppelt so
viele intensivbetten benötigen für
corona patienten deshalb schichten sie
jetzt um zwischen den stationen und wenn
auch das nicht mehr ausreicht müssen sie
patienten verlegen dann wohl auch in
andere bundesländer eine
besorgniserregende und problematische
situation die sich auch im aktuellen
zdf-politbarometer spiegelt antje pieper
hat die neuesten zahlen ist jetzt bei
uns im studio hallo anzusehen denn die
bürgerinnen und bürger aktuell die
größten probleme also zunächst mal ist
corona für die meisten der befragten
wieder zum wichtigsten problem in
deutschland geworden da gab es was
parallel zu den wachsenden instanzen
einen rasanten anstieg 57 prozent wären
in corona inzwischen noch vor klima und
umweltschutz vor zwei wochen waren es
nur 24 prozent
und die unzufriedenheit mit den bisher
ergriffenen maßnahmen ist ebenso rasant
gestiegen nur noch 32 prozent finden sie
gerade richtig für 49 prozent müssten
sie härter ausfallen
die frage was resultiert daraus in bezug
auf die aktuellen corona maßnahmen also
eine deutliche mehrheit ist für eine
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
71 prozent der befragten befürworten das
für beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen und
in der pflege 65 prozent für schulen und
kitas auch für eine zweig regel in
restaurants im freizeit und
kulturbereich sind ungefähr zwei drittel
der befragten für 3g am arbeitsplatz
sind 71 prozent und mehr als drei
viertel der befragten meinen übrigens
auch dass die einhaltung der maßnahmen
besser kontrolliert werden sollte dann
vielen dank an antje pieper das war nur
ein kleiner ausschnitt und alle fragen
und antworten zum politbarometer können
sie ab 22 uhr im heute journal sehen und
schon jetzt und jederzeit online in
unserer zdf heute app dort finden sie
auch alle zahlen und grafiken noch mal
zum durchklicken
in sachen corona jetzt ein blick ins
europäische ausland die bundesregierung
stuft österreich tschechien und ungarn
ab sonntag wieder als hochrisiko gebiet
ein das bedeutet wer aus diesen ländern
einreiste nicht vollständig geimpft oder
genießen ist muss eben quarantäne wegen
des rasanten anstiegs der
infektionsfälle plant die
österreichische regierung einen lock
down für die die nicht geimpft sind
die welt schaut nach glasgow viel steht
auf dem spiel bei der klimakonferenz
fast zwei wochen wurde verhandelt im
mittelpunkt die frage wie kann die
erderwärmung möglichst auf 1,5 grad
begrenzt werden glasgow muss liefern so
machten die demonstrierenden druck auf
die verhandler heute ist letzte
gipfeltag aber die verhandlungen die
gehen wohl in die verlängerung aus
glasgow diana zimmermann
zwei wochen harter verhandlungen liegen
hinter den teilnehmern der
internationalen klimakonferenz doch das
abschlussdokument muss von fast 200
staaten einstimmig verabschiedet werden
und noch wird gestritten als gastgeber
der kopf 26 versucht der britische
premier selbst aus einem impfzentrum
heraus noch mal druck
das ist der moment sagt euren
verhandlungsteams wie wichtig das ist
sagt ihnen sie sollen die überzeugung
und den mut aufbringen sich zu einigen
und diese abschluss erklärung aber sucht
verschreiben noch uneins ist man sich
etwa über gelder mit denen ärmeren
staaten nach naturkatastrophen geholfen
werden soll doch ergebnisse sind
absehbar zum ersten mal überhaupt wird
der ausstieg aus fossilen brennstoffen
gefordert allerdings wurde die
formulierung im momentan vorliegenden
text abgeschwächt der deutsche umwelt
staatssekretär jochen flasbarth
verhandelt für die eu er wertet es auch
als erfolg dass die usa und china sich
gemeinsam verpflichten das treibhausgas
methan deutlich zu reduzieren
es war ja auch richtig und gut und er
hofft dass china jetzt hier seine
klimaschutzanstrengungen noch mal erhöht
hat das brauchen wir auch um bis 2030 zu
so starken minderung zu kommen dass wir
dann das 1 5 grad ziel wirklich
tatsächlich noch in reichweite halten
auch könnten sich die staaten noch
darauf verständigen dass sie ihre
klimaziele schon im nächsten jahr
nachbessern alles wie zu spät zu
kritisieren demonstranten vor dem
konferenzgebäude die allgemein
anerkannte rote linie ist eine erwärmung
bis höchstens 1,5 grad aber selbst wenn
alle ziele dieser konferenz eingehalten
werden steuert die erde noch auf 2 4
grad zu
und auch wenn es für eine bilanz zu früh
ist volker angres in glasgow wie ist
denn ihr eindruck nach fast zwei wochen
gipfel kommt die welt vor allem versucht
die klimakatastrophe aufzuhalten
die welt kommt langsam voran das liegt
daran dass diese un-konferenz natürlich
ein prozess ist das abkommen von paris
als klimaschutzabkommen da müssen alle
länder mitgenommen werden das bedeutet
immer der kleinste gemeinsame nenner das
kostet viel zeit aber immerhin alle
haben sich darauf verständigt 1,5 grad
erwärmung ja das muss das wimmelt sein
und alle haben auch gesagt so bis mitte
des jahrhunderts da müssen alle länder
klimaneutral sein das sagen auch große
konzerne bp war hier bmw war hirn stv
hier und die wollen dass andere gerne
machen aber ein punkt der noch offen ist
das scheitert im moment noch am artikel
6 des klimaabkommens der regelt nämlich
die internationale zusammenarbeit und
diese regeln die braucht man um
internationale klimaschutzprojekte dann
in gang zu bringen das sind dann sehr
sehr große projekte und die braucht man
einfach klein klein den klimaschutz das
reicht nicht mehr die großen projekte
die sind und wir hoffen dass dieser
artikel 6 vielleicht in dieser nacht
noch ausverhandelt wird und
verabschiedet wird danke und grüße nach
glasgow volker angres wir schauen jetzt
auch das rennen um den cdu vorsitz da
wird konkreter und offizieller gleich
zwei kandidaten haben heute erklärt sich
als nachfolger für armin laschet zu
bewerben zum einen außenpolitiker
norbert wird können und zum anderen
kanzleramtsminister helge braun und
erstmals werden die parteimitglieder
entscheiden wer chef oder chefin der cdu
wird aus berlin berichtet winnie
heescher noch ist armin laschet cdu chef
er wollte dass die kandidatin für seine
nachfolge sich auf eine teamlösung
hinter den kulissen einigen das hat
nicht geklappt mehrere männer wollen es
nun wissen einer präsentiert sich am
morgen der presse norbert röttgen
außenpolitiker jurist aus
nordrhein-westfalen wichtigste aufgabe
die er sieht die cdu in der mitte halten
wenn wir auch nur signalisieren wenn es
auch nur wahrgenommen würde die machen
platz in der mitte um an anderer stelle
etwas zu suchen und sich zu orientieren
dann wäre das das größte geschenk an spd
grüne und fdp die frau im schlepptau
will er im fall seiner wahl zur
generalsekretärin machen franziska
hoppermann aus hamburg gerade in den
bundestag eingezogen bislang
kommunalpolitikerin wir haben etwa
400.000 mitglieder viele davon sind vor
ort engagiert in der kommunalpolitik
engagiert in ganz vielen verschiedenen
gesellschaftlichen gruppen eingebunden
dieses know-how müssen wir nutzen und
dieses know how müssen wir mehr
einbeziehen und es muss mehr zur sprache
kommen im januar war norbert röttgen
armin laschet im rennen um den
parteivorsitz unterlegen der
konservativere friedrich merz auch
dessen kandidatur wird in der partei
noch erwartet ein anderer hat die
zumindest intern schon erklärt helge
braun aus hessen mediziner bislang
merkels kanzleramtsminister er will sich
und sein team am montag präsentieren
noch bis mittwoch läuft die
bewerbungsfrist für den chefposten der
zehnten
von der cdu zu den ampel verhandlungen
laufen weiter sehr vertraulich ab viel
trinkt nicht nach außen alles was die 22
arbeitsgruppen nicht zu ende bringen
soll ab montag in spitzenrunden weiter
und zu ende verhandelt werden jetzt
lässt ein interview mit dem
grünen-vorsitzenden habeck aufhorchen
ein scheitern der koalitionsgespräche
wird offenbar nicht ganz ausgeschlossen
chuck unterlag energie hat alle
politischen umdrehungen in berlin im
blick was ist da los also robert habeck
hat heute zwei dinge gemacht er hat zum
einen ein klein wenig den vorhang
gelüftet über den verhandlungen von
denen ja alle immer gesagt haben es sei
sehr harmonisch und ganz so harmonisch
scheint das nicht zu sein vor allem beim
klimaschutz sagt er zieht sich das ganze
wie ein altes kaugummi und macht klar
dass aus sicht der grünen spd und fdp
sich da noch bewegen müssen und er
stellt eine grüne wand oder auf vor der
entscheidenden phase der verhandlungen
in dem er sagt wenn man sich nicht auf
geeignete maßnahmen ein nicht um das 1,5
grad ziel zu erreichen dann seien die
koalitionsverhandlungen gescheitert wie
ernst er das meint und wie ernst die
grünen ist damit meinen das wird man
dann noch sehen müssen aber die aussage
steht im raum dass im zweifel vielleicht
diesmal die grünen sagen lieber nicht
regieren als um 1,5 grad ziel
vorbeizuregieren danke schack und anna
bleibt also spannend seit mehr als einem
jahr ist stefan harwardt präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes cola bedingt
war der festakt zur amtsübernahme
verschoben worden heute holte man das
nach zur feier nach karlsburg haben die
wichtigsten vertreterinnen und vertreter
der bundesrepublik
bundespräsident steinmeier würdigte in
seiner rede die arbeit des
verfassungsgerichtes die entscheidungen
aus karlsruhe hätten eine signalwirkung
über deutschland hinaus
zum flüchtlings konflikt mit belarus da
will die türkei jetzt keine menschen aus
syrien dem irak und dem jemen mehr nach
belarus fliegen lassen und auch der irak
stoppt die direktflüge dorthin zuvor
hatte die eu mit strafmassnahmen gegen
fluggesellschaften gedroht die migranten
nach minsk befördern die eu wirft dem
belarussischen regime vor als vergeltung
für sanktionen gezielt flüchtlinge in
die europäische union zu schleusen viele
wurden an der polnischen grenze
zurückgewiesen und sitzen dort jetzt zu
tausenden fest
nach china wo präsident ski seine macht
ausweitet mit einer historischen
resolution hat die kommunistische partei
den weg für seine dritte vielleicht
sogar lebenslange amtszeit geebnet in
offiziellen dokumenten wird sie als
begründer einer neuen ära aufgeführt
damit stellte sich auf eine stufe mit
dem früheren mächtigen parteichef deng
xiaoping und staatsgründer mao tse tung
stefanie schöneborn mit den details in
china schreibt ab heute nur eine
geschichte
er hat sich historisch in der bedeutung
der kommunistischen partei verewigt und
damit seinen führungsanspruch zementiert
die partei hat es abgesegnet einstimmig
widerspruch darf es in diesem land nicht
mehr geben ab jetzt sind skis gedanken
nationale glaubenssätze für jeden
die plenarsitzung fordert die partei und
alle mitglieder auf sich um das
zentralkomitee mit genossen skijumping
als kern zu vereinen
so viel macht wie camping jetzt auf eine
person vereint hatte in china zuletzt
war zu tun nun schreibt jean ping die
geschichte um wie die zukunft seine
zukunft denn mit der resolution sichert
er sich seine position als präsident die
allmacht des führers der kommunistischen
partei kehrt zurück um mit ihr der
personenkult um
dieses neu geschichtsbild schießen pings
verleiht ihnen die macht um immer mehr
einfluss auf wirtschaftspolitik innen
und außenpolitik zu nehmen kritische
stimmen die sich auch nur über
politische verfolgung oder fehltritte
äußern die werden immer mehr verstummen
die bilder des ein parteien plenums
wirken wie bilder aus der vergangenheit
aber doping sieht in dem ein
parteiensystem die zukunft und die
überlegenheit des chinesischen systems
über den westlichen demokratien
für ihn ist chinas zeit gekommen
weltmacht nummer eins zu werden
[Musik]
nummer eins war auch deutscher beim
fußball damit sind wir beim sport und
katja das war ja gestern gala-auftritt
der fußball-nationalmannschaft
wahrscheinlich extra zum abschied für
den ex-bundestrainer wahrscheinlich über
den gibt es übrigens eine tolle doko in
der zdf mediathek aber in der tat 9 zu 0
besiegt die deutsche
fußball-nationalmannschaft liechtenstein
im vorletzten wm-qualifikationsspiel
allerdings war es auch ein abend mit
folgen vor allem für leon goretzka und
für die kommende aufstellung beim
letzten spiel des jahres übermorgen in
jerewan das team von hansi flick reist
ohne fünf spieler nach armenien darunter
zwei bayern profis manuel neuer wird
geschont und leon goretzka hat sich nach
diesem tritt von jens hofer eine
prellung zugezogen ist nicht
einsatzfähig der liechtensteiner sah die
rote karte entschuldigte sich und
begleitete goretzka vom platz eine
schöne geste auch dass beim löw abschied
viele ex spieler und wegbegleiter
spalier standen letztendlich war auch
ziel dass wir google läuft seinem
abschied wir noch mal ein schönes ein
attraktives fußballspiel zeigen und das
ist der mannschaft auch gelungen die
kombinationen und neun tore erfreuten
auch den ex bundestrainer den schönsten
treffer schoss der wolfsburger riedle
baku sein erster im nationalteam sechs
siege in den ersten sechs spielen hat
außer fliegt noch kein anderer
bundestrainer geschafft wir wissen
natürlich auch dass das die gegner jetzt
nicht das kaliber
die top 10 auch haben und wir wollen
dahin und deswegen dieses ob ich das was
solche spiele auch gewinnen ein abend
zwischen tor party und löw abschied
danke jogi war zu lesen die atmosphäre
samt ehrung zum jahrhunderttrainer
ergaben einen würdigen rahmen
eine positive überraschung gab's gestern
beim deutschland-cup dem einzigen test
für deutschlands eishockey
nationalmannschaft vor den kommenden
spielen in peking denn das team von
bundestrainer söder holm hat
überraschend olympiasieger russland mit
4 zu 3 besiegt
professionelle freude beim bundestrainer
sein ersatzgeschwächtes team mit viel
kampfgeist kontrahent russland führt
früh mit 2 0 aber das dhb team dreht das
spiel bergmann zehnte minute eins zu
zwei elis mit dem ausgleich in der 13
minute förder mit der ersten führung und
schließlich tobias rieder mit dem 4 2
nach 42 minuten russland noch mit einem
tor das aber ändert nichts mehr 4 zu 3
für deutschland der nächste gegner ist
am samstag die schweiz
und die bilder die morgen abend hier in
bern katja und wir gehen noch mal ins
all richtung iss nach bilderbuch start
und rund 20 flugstunden ist der deutsche
astronaut maura oben angekommen
angedockt ging es von der kapsel ab
durch die luke in die iss große freude
dann bei der gesamten crew und gleich
die erste herausforderung ein
persönliches elfi in der
schwerelosigkeit wie geht das denn
maurer hat übrigens gleich aus dem
fenster auf die erde geschaut der
ausblick sei wunderschön und er schickt
liebe grüße nach deutschland zur erde wo
übrigens neuer regen unterwegs ist mehr
dazu erfahren wir gleich von austin
healey christian sieh was erwartet sie
um 22 uhr im heute journal von uns war
es das gerne bis morgen würden uns sehr
freuen schönen dank schönen abend und
schönen start ins wochenende
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter es wird wieder nass und diesmal
mit regen also nicht nur nebel und das
liegt an diesem tief über der nordsee
was sich allmählich weiter nach süden
verlagert und einmal deutschland
überquert bis in den mittelmeerraum in
der nacht im westen also dichte
bewölkung und auch nach norden in
beträgen das verlagert sich langsam
südwärts aber im süden herrscht häufig
teils dichter nebel temperaturen dazu
bis minus ein grad in der eifel und 7
grad am niederrhein dass die
temperaturspanne aber in der mitte
häufig werte um die null grad marke
morgen am vormittag also im westen viele
wolken und regen das verlagert sich
richtung main ganz im süden auch mal
sonnenschein die in der norddeutschen
tiefebene aber zum nachmittag sieht das
anders aus im süden dann vermehrt wolken
und regen im norden zwar trocken aber
trübe und das bei temperaturen bis 13
grad am niederrhein und 6 grad im
vogtland die kommenden tage am sonntag
dann noch etwas regen das verabschiedet
sich langsam bei sechs bis zwölf grad
montag ruhiger unter sonnenschein oder
nebel bei 6 bis 12 und dienstag kühler
fünf bis zehn grad ein schöner abend